[Music]
this morning on the dish we take you to
london to meet one of the city's most
distinctive chefs
british-born andrew wong is awarded his
second michelin star this year
for his unique interpretation of the
cuisine of china
wong meticulously researches traditions
and tastes across the vast nation and
brings the wealth of detail and history
to every dish he creates mts taya went
to meet him
and sample some true delights
but a little bit in a box each one there
is precision
and then there is andrew wong's
precision
the british-born chinese chef channels 3
000 years of chinese cooking technique
into his 21st century innovations his
restaurant a
wong won its first michelin star in 2017
and a second this year the first time a
chinese restaurant
outside of asia has received such an
honor roger why do we have a knife and
fork on the table
are we uh what are we trying to say
about myself and my guest
we met up to discuss his life career and
what inspires him
let's start from the beginning who's
andrew wong
i was born in london and my parents my
father's side of the family is from
sichuan and my mother was
um is from hong kong and tell you the
truth i never
imagined i would become a chef being a
chef isn't
exactly the the the occupation of choice
for the children of immigrants exactly
wong's family business was in
restaurants
but his parents wanted him to get an
education
so i initially studied chemistry oxford
i mean your parents have been pretty
happy about that
why until i got kicked out why um well i
had i had quite a poor attendance record
switching to anthropology wong was at
the london school of economics when his
father
who had run the family restaurant for
years suddenly died
when my father passed away it was it was
a realization that
i had to have to grow up
and i had to grow up fast that
restaurant is now the location of his
own eatery
named after his parents albert and annie
and i remember for the first years i was
a chef my parents
my mom didn't want to tell people that i
was i was good i was like
he's still deciding whether he wants to
go to law school but actually she was
she's been a great
great support for me but she's the first
one to to tell me when i'm doing things
wrong
obviously always right for michelin star
judges
there's little the chef can do wrong his
take on the cantonese brunch time staple
dim sum which translates as touching
heart is an assortment of small plates
steamed savory and fried
i'm staring at what looks like grass
[Laughter]
and what look like mushrooms so it's a
bun
it's a steamed bun it's a steamed bun
inside is mushrooms
okay and again it's just one it's just
to be playful you know dim sum is meant
to be playful you know people are men
sitting around table have a la
wong takes even the humblest of
ingredients and supercharges them
with flavor i have my eye on
what looks like a seashell
the chicken wing it's a chicken wing a
chicken wing
so it's a it's a chicken wing that's
been marinated and fermented bean curd
wow and what's that on top of it it's
a basic diced up snail with ginger and
garlic and chili
okay so i'll take that but there are two
bones in that wing there are okay
it's like a proper chicken wing yeah
because it's like sacrilege to
be removing bones from a chicken wing in
chinese culture yeah
yeah do you feel like this really
represents
you as a british-born
chinese person you know i'm not an
expert on chinese food but i
i'd like to think that i'm aspiring to
be an expert on
my chinese food and the chinese food
that we serve at a wong
and that's real all i can really answer
for um as a chef
and as someone who has come from um
a background of chineseness
within an international city
collaborating with food anthropologist
dr mukhta das
wong frequently travels to china to
explore chinese food history
recipes and ingredients but he hasn't
forgotten the community he grew up with
in london we're in the middle of a
global pandemic
um it's been pretty tough for a lot of
chinese restaurants family restaurants
how are you feeling at this moment
you know initially back in march there
was this kind of the stigma
of of the chinese community um
and there was this india reaction you
know if you looked at
my friends in chinatown for example
their restaurants were completely
empty right but the the glimmer of hope
that i saw was that when restaurants
reopened
actually people went back to chinese
restaurants very very quickly
but i do think that nowadays chinese
cuisine
and chinese culture is an important part
of british culture
for wong and his family food is at the
heart of that
you've said this before this is your
dad's restaurant it's now yours
it's doing phenomenally well uh
what do you think your dad would have
made of all of this um
that's that's a hard one um
because he would have been proud of what
we've achieved
but no but he would not have been proud
for the journey it took to get here
and because he much would have preferred
me to be a doctor um
even still with two michelin stars i
think so i have the sauce for the potato
for cbs this morning saturday infio's
tied london
two michelin stars aside though i i i'm
telling you
i cannot wait to dive into that next
trip right i love it
let's do it hey wong next time we go to
london there i'll tell you what though
that's a hardcore dad right two michelin
stars and he's not to wouldn't be
wouldn't be thrilled with that it's
pretty amazing when you're the child of
immigrants like that though because
doctor is a known career path michelin
stars are not commonplace
yeah yeah i have to tell you that voice
of his love it